Tại vì hợp tại sáng rơi là ngày bàn 18 năm,
tổng thống Pháp em and landmark Mà Crom cạnh bảo chia dẻ dưới mỹ và Trung Quốc,
là mùi đe dọa lần nhất đổi với chất tự tận gạo hiện nay,
đông thời kêu góa xây dự gắc lên mình hành động dựa pháp và các lỗi táp ảnh đổ dương,
hãy mình dương ông Mà Crom giữa mạnh pháp là đồng mình của Mỹ,
nhưng bận ruy trí hợp tác với Trung Quốc,
theo ông Nếu thế giới bị buộc ở Tròn Fé,
đón bộ hệ thống thế chế tòn gầu sau thế trên hài sẽ bị pháp ở ớt,
trong thống Pháp cũng khẳng định đã để lúc cận gạo lên mình thức chất không phủ thuộc,
nhằm đối pho với các thách thức như Trung nghĩa Sét Lại,
Trung nghĩa không bố, Trung nghĩa phổ biến bụng khí hát nhân và vấn đề khủng hòa khí hậu,
trong thống Pháp đồng thời kia góa cho ông và cú tụt cho á thái bình dương,
cùng túc này quán hệ đối tác, để bảo vệ chất tự dựa trên đột lệ,
cạnh tranh công nghệ và bảo vệ các giả chị phố quát,
trong bối cạnh mất ông tòn gầu.